we will see a lot of innovation because
this is an empty space it just
just began to in these activities
[Music]
y'all been vanessa thank you for being
on my show how are you
i'm fine thank you really great to have
you here i
i'm gonna learn about aging in the next
20 minutes you're an
expert in the logitivity space you're
actually named both in
2019 and 2020 one of israel's top
influencers
and experts on in the longevity space
the ceo of mediterranean towers ventures
but you're
also running a private clinic and you
mentioned that that's leftovers from the
from the first degree so i'll have to
understand a little bit why
but yeah we have to start with the fun
fact because who doesn't like chocolate
me i hate
i think i'm i'm unique in that space but
but really i cannot eat it
it's like somebody saying that they
don't like music
i know but really if you want to
surprise me please
do not bring chocolate bring flowers
i love it okay yeah first of all before
we even dive deep into your
personal journey give me a little bit of
background as to what is what is the
longevity space what is this thing
called
aging 2.0 that you're that you're so
passionate about
okay well we all know that the world is
getting older
if we are looking what is happening now
there are around 12 percent of the
population that are 60 and above
if you are looking at the year 2030
there will be 16 of the population that
are 60 and above
and in the year 2050 there will be more
than 20 percent
that means that every fifth person in
the world
is going to be older adult and this
changes
our whole society and this opens
a huge market and opportunity
for innovation and if we as a society
wants to continue and provide
services to a growing population and
still we have a limit
in our budget there's no other solution
than to develop technologies
so i think this is the only way that we
should go
we should really implant the
technologies in our services
in our life in order to have quality of
life
and not just live longer so you're
saying that in the next dozen
years we're going to see that one in
five people in the world are going to be
elderly yet and and that's a fantastic
case as to why we need to continue
innovating and put
at least i'm imagining a fifth of our
innovative efforts
on the elderly population if not more
because they act because
a lot of the times they need more
assistance right than the younger
generation
yet you know if i look at the landscape
of startups and of innovations that are
happening today i don't think a fifth of
them
are dealing with the longevity space is
that right
that's why i think there's a challenge
yes because i think the demographic
change
had began um just now because the baby
boomers the ones that were born
after world war ii they are just now
entering what we are called the being
older adult
so we just in the i think in the
four three years we can see the change
that is developing
and we can see the the big companies are
trying to enter the market we can see
apple watch uh that is it's a senior
apple watch we can see
amazon we can see best buy all of them
are opening
departments for technologies or products
for the elderly
and we will see the change this period
the kovit 19 period
have done really big things with with
elderly and
and how we approach elderly and this is
not only
about being vulnerable or someone that
is a
being fraud it's all about having a good
life
opportunities being active in the
society and what will happen now if i
have to stay at home because it's too
dangerous outside how
do i continue my my my life my my
activities
and technology is the answer so so y'all
give me a little bit of background as to
what needs to happen
in the longevity space so in order for
us to
to accommodate for the growing elderly
population and to be able to
to to you know to conti to help
improving their lives as well
what sort of what space is within the
longevity space do we need to focus on
is this
is it a health care is it loneliness is
it
communication what do you think well
aging 2.0 which is organization it's an
international organizat
organization based in san francisco but
it has
a i think almost 150 ambassadors all
over the world we are the
the israeli ambassadors they defined
eight
segments in in which we can see
technologies for aging well
the first one is engagement and purpose
the second one is financial wellness
mobility and movement daily living and
lifestyle
caregiving or care coordination
brain health and the end of life in each
segment
we can see a various of technologies
like virtual reality augmented reality
robots iot
artificial intelligence material
learning this
type of technology is not important it
is the space that they are connected
with
and if we will invest in those area we
will see
individual well-being and well health
we can see a work workforce
participation because people
will be able to work longer we will see
a raise at the consumption because
people will buy more
things so they will continue and develop
the
the economic that um of the country
we will see a lot of innovation because
this is an empty space it just
just began to in in this case out of
those eight
eight segments that you were talking
about which one are you most attracted
to because
you know i could it could make a very
strong case as to why you should be
passionate about all of them
but what really gets you excited i think
that
continue your lifestyle and daily living
will make the the biggest change in our
life
so can you clarify what does that mean
that people will not
stop living the way they're living just
because they're getting older and
they're having more challenges because
of their physiology this is
exactly what i'm saying it doesn't
matter if you cannot leave your home
if you have some disability you will
continue your
favorite lifestyle you will continue to
be active in your community in your
family
do what you like to do and
even if you if you will stay at your
home that doesn't mean that you will not
have a community
to be engaged in or friends or family
or or doing whatever you want
learning something new right so
but i'm thinking still yeah today you
know the past 20 years we've had such a
boom in
in consumer technology and things that
are helping us live our lives better
yet you know even my own grandparents
who are 85
and you know they have a phone and
everything there's still
there's no technology that is helping us
communicate better
and is helping and is helping adapt
between the generation gaps and i'm
thinking about my
my six-year-old niece and my 85 year old
grandmother they they love talking to
each other
and it's getting it you know i can just
imagine that if they will be
disconnected geographically it'll be
nearly impossible
to bridge that communication gap so why
even today isn't there any
any any practical solutions for these
because the market is already here
well there is but there is a lack of
knowledge
there is a lack of knowledge at your
side as a family
member and the lack of knowledge in in
your grandmother or grandfather
side so we are doing
what we can in order to spread the rumor
but it's hard
um i personally have a segment in one of
the
of the commercial tv channels in one of
the morning shows
so i'm trying to spread the word that
there are solutions that are
wonderful solution even even for people
that are
not technologies at all they don't know
how
how to operate a zoom they don't know
how to push a button they don't know how
to operate
the whatsapp video there is a technology
using the
tv screen or or even just using
a regular screen that is not a tv that
when you schedule
in an hour the conversation the video
conversation will be open
the the person just have to sit in front
of the screen
and that's right
and the cost is so low really
right around one dollar a day it's
nothing
but people do not know so
definitely no i actually i participated
in a hackathon here in palo alto
at y combinator a few months ago with my
friends from stanford and we developed
this app where we put a camera on the tv
and when the grandchild calls their
grandfather or grandmother on the phone
it it shows on their tv and then all the
all the elderly person has to do is wave
in front of the camera and it'll
open more for the accessibility side but
but you know
we were still shocked that the number of
solutions even though
even if a few do exist it's still very
limited but yeah i'd love to learn a
little bit about it more about what
you're doing
specifically with mediterranean towers
ventures and how specifically
you got into this because you're very
young
you can be you know you're you can be
doing anything else and people doing
venture capital yet you're excited
about the longevity space and i have to
really understand why
well it all started years ago i was a
young physiotherapist working
one of the hmos and my grandma was a
resident in one of the nursing homes
in my hometown and one night the staff
were not close
they didn't close the bars of the bed
properly
and the bus fell down and she rolled
over and she hit their head in the
wheelchair that was standing near the
bed
and she died from a brain hemorrhage so
at that point
i made a decision that this will never
happen again i quit my job
i went to learn rehabilitation and
geriatrics and start working
in rehabilitation centers and in nursery
homes
with the elderly people and i just loved
it
and i continue looking for solutions
that this sort of things will never
happen again
and and then i joined the society the
electrical and electronic engineering
society in israel they opened a new
group
technologies for aging well and i was
elected as the chairman
and we started as a 14 people around one
table
and we really didn't know what to do
and now we are more than one thousand
five hundred hundred members
a very active ecosystem and we are very
proud
we joined aging 2.0 that is an
international organization
and two years ago two and a half years
ago
a mediterranean towers venture which is
a publicly traded company
they came to one of our conference and
they said
that they want to open a cvc corporate
venture capital
and invest in technologies for aging
well mediterranean towers
group is um a company that is running
independent living facilities in israel
that's the biggest private
private uh independent living
facilities in israel and we opened the
fund
this is the only venture capital in
israel that invest in the
this space and we are very very proud
wow and we open even if we don't invest
in a company we open
our facilities for focus group or for
better testing
and we try really to give a push to the
whole ecosystem in israel right it
sounds like it's beyond just
another venture capital firm this is the
you know it's a mission-driven
fund that is you know that is about the
community and about fostering
an innovative community in the startup
nation to help
also motivate more people to create
companies in this space
so even if you don't invest you're
actually helping them continuing to grow
and develop and develop their
relationship with them it's not just you
know
a financial transaction it's much more
about a community right
right we're doing each year we're doing
a competition
and our judges is not just a
panelist of experts it's also our
get residence chance to vote and they
get the chance to ask their
entrepreneurs all the questions
and they're really doing a great job
it's not easy to stand on on the stage
and to to answer their questions because
they have a
very good questions and we are very
proud that they
they really are active and they shape
the next generation of products for the
elderly
generation so you know putting on
the investment hat are the returns in
the space
the same as you know in in other spaces
like cyber security
and and and other consumer technologies
like what what are the differences
between
the longevity space and investing
exclusively
or or primarily in the longevity space
rather than
you know other funds that may be
focusing on other industries
well first of all we are focused in
in the space and not in the technology
so i think we are very young space
so the number of exits are
um really small but we can see
we can see the trend we can see that all
these
um technologies are raising when
i think two years ago we saw most of the
companies raising seed money
now we can see they passed a round right
and they are continuing to develop hours
we made three
investments all of them uh are now past
eight rounds
wow so we're very proud and it's only
two years ago so
what happens fast and we can see the
trend we can see the
really the the potential in this area
it's like fintech five years ago you
have
patience yeah but it will happen
definitely it will happen so yeah for
myself and for for you know my friends
who are who are
watching this we're also considering
what what to start their next venture
and as we know you know especially in
israel
it is very common out of the out of the
intelligence students to go more into
the cyber security spaces and those
types of fields
but but i'd love to hear a few ideas
just to get the juices running for young
entrepreneurs
that are thinking of of what to do next
and and
i want to understand really what are the
opportunities in this space maybe you
can give me
you know two or three high level ideas
of problems that one can tackle
in the aging and longevity space we're
using technology
well first of all when we are talking
about the technologies for aging well
we are talking about a platform that
will combine
several services because you cannot put
a lot of devices in your house and use
them
in the same time it's too complicated
and it's too expensive
so you have to build a platform that
will give a service
service and the service must
solve some need right cyber security is
nice
but it it doesn't solve a problem for me
as an individual
but as an older adult that wants to
continue
and live his life like he was used to do
it must solve
a problem some need this is
a very big difference and i think that
every
entrepreneur that is entering the space
must think
about who is the customer and who is the
player
it's not the same person most of the
time right
and it's a little bit complicated but if
if i'm comparing this to
the younger generation you must
understand that the product that you are
selling for
a three years old child is not the same
product that you will
sell for a 16 years old child this is
the same
as the older adult population you cannot
sell the same product for
a 65 years old person or to a 90
year old person this is a huge
population
a lot of segmentation in a segment
tension especially
the ability
to perform your activity how activity
you are
you have to segment to do a good
segmentation
of the population and know who is your
customer what you are selling
and who will want to pay for it i i
think that's that's fascinating and i've
been thinking quite a bit about this
space and and one of the things that
really intrigued me is that
this space um more so than a lot of
others
like you said a lot of times the person
who is using your product is not
necessarily the person who's buying the
product
and you have yeah so you have like a
almost like a
two-sided marketplace and you have to
you have to really understand where the
moving players
in this puzzle but but it's really
really fascinating yeah
so as i understand you know the passion
that you're coming in
doing this do you see yourself staying
in this space for for a long time i know
that you also are
are still practicing from your original
profession
out of a love for that profession but
but do you see yourself continuing with
that mission for for many years to come
or is this something that you're saying
i want to make a dent now and
potentially later i'll move on to
to different industries no i would say
in this industry it has a huge potential
i saw more than 250 companies in
three years i i see i see the activity
i have a lot of knowledge today that i
didn't have four years ago
i won't give it to our entrepreneurs
and really to to put israel as the
leading country for age tech in the
world
i love it okay and on that node yell i
need three words that you would use to
describe yourself
and i and i need you to to explain a
little bit about about these words
well i'm i'm perfection is the person
i love perfection really i have to
to learn about everything and to
understand it
until i make a decision
i love a good life really i'm having a
good life i love to coming
to my work um i'm coming every day
with with the passion i see a lot of new
things
and i i feel that i can contribute to
the space
and the last word is a blonde
just the color i'm not a user drawing
i love yes
it's really fun because when people see
me and they know
my my degree that i have a phd in
geriatrics but and
when i come to a conference or to a
meeting they say wow
you i said yes i'm shaping my future
um for me
my future will look different well your
future but it sounds like you're also in
the process of helping
millions if not billions of others down
the line so shaping your future while
shaping everybody else's future as well
yeah thank you very very much for the
inspiration this was wonderful
i'm personally very passionate about the
space that you're in and and so and
that's why it was so
i was so excited when you agreed to do
this episode with me and i hope that
you know i'll definitely take an active
part in the space and i hope that my
friends both at stanford and 9200
will also consider this as a viable path
in their entrepreneurship journey and
thank you for thank you for all the
insights over the past 20 minutes
thank you take care bye